harris and vice president pence thank
you for being here a sharp exchange over
the trump administration's handling of
the coronavirus pandemic
started the debate whatever the vice
president is claiming the administration
has done
clearly it hasn't worked when you're
looking at over
and 210 thousand dead bodies in our
country american lives
that have been lost families that are
grieving that loss
and you know the vice president is the
head of the task force
but when you say what the american
people have done over these last eight
months hasn't
worked that's a great disservice
to the sacrifices the american people
have made so let's talk about
caring about the american people the
american people have had to sacrifice
far too much
because of the incompetence of this
administration
pence dodged a question about the rose
garden ceremony that became a super
spreader event
it was an outdoor event which all of our
scientists regularly and routinely
advise the difference here
is president trump and i trust the
american people
to make choices in the best interest of
their health
harris fired back let's talk about
respecting the american people
you respect the american people when you
tell them the truth but look
senator harris you're you're entitled to
your own opinion but the candidates
clashed over the economy
taxes and sharply over global warming
which harris called an existential
threat we have seen a pattern with this
administration which is they don't
believe in science
and joe's plan is about saying we're
going to deal with it but we're also
going to create jobs
donald trump when asked about the
wildfires in california
and and the question was you know the
science is telling us this you know what
donald trump
said science doesn't know we don't need
a massive
2 trillion dollar green new deal that
would impose all new mandates on
american businesses
and american families there were flashes
reminiscent of the chaotic trump biden
debate
as pence repeatedly interrupted and
talked over harris
but she remained calm mr vice president
i'm speaking
if you don't mind letting me finish we
can then have a conversation okay
please okay senator harris other issues
discussed
included racial justice policing reform
and the rise of white supremacists
i want everyone to know who puts on the
uniform of law enforcement every day
president trump and i stand with you and
the reality of this is
that we are talking about an election in
27 days
where last week the president of the
united states took a debate stage in
front of 70 million americans
and refused to condemn white
supremacists
whether any of the exchanges in this
debate will change many voters minds
remains to be seen
meanwhile both pence and harris as well
as biden
will be campaigning on thursday in
arizona
a swing state where polls show biden is
leading
rob reynolds al jazeera salt lake city